revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya rosa pérez más degustado
conmigo en el estudio rosa bienvenida
buena mañana de viernes vamos por
supuesto abrir esta revista de prensa
con lo que ocurre actualmente en este
momento en la central nuclear de sabor y
allá en ucrania la más grande de europa
recordemos que el día de ayer fue
desconectada totalmente esta planta de
la central eléctrica ucraniana que
proporciona el 20 por ciento de energía
a ese país la primera vez en la historia
que sucede eso ucrania acusó a los rusos
los rusos acusaron al ucraniano como
siempre pasa pues a lo largo de lo que
ha pasado en esta en esta guerra en este
conflicto en las partes pues se acusan
mutuamente
precisamente hoy en el guatón la empresa
que puedes pública ucraniana que maneja
estas cuatro centrales nucleares en
ucrania anunció que ya reactivó uno de
los seis reactores de la planta se
espera que reactiven otro más hasta el
momento pues solamente uno está re
conectado a esta red eléctrica esto es
un poco el contexto lo que está pasando
como lo señale entonces el chief
independent efectivamente muchas gracias
por esta introducción raúl y recordemos
que sin embargo se activaron
en generadores de diésel para evitar que
los reactores se calentaran durante este
lapso en que esta central ha sido
desconectada de la red eléctrica
ucraniana como decía cell a kiev
independent señala que un bombardeo ruso
desconectó la planta nuclear de esa
polilla de la red ucraniana dice el
operador como bien insistía hay
acusaciones cruzadas de cuál fue el
desencadenante de esta desconexión no y
para digamos a señalar lo que bien
decías cómo ha ido pasando a lo largo de
estos seis meses de guerra estas
acusaciones contradictorias vamos a leer
un párrafo de este artículo del kiev
independent que dice occidente y ucrania
han acusado a rusia de usar la planta
como escudo y herramienta de chantaje en
medio de amenazas de contraofensiva en
el sur sputnik y rosa por el total al
lado contrario sputnik a título corto a
la última línea eléctrica de la central
nuclear de sap orilla no hay forma de
suministrar electricidad a ucrania esta
es la cita de antoni coll stop quienes
se la gobierna de la zona ocupada de sap
orilla no el representante del kremlin
que rusia ha puesto pues en esta región
y un párrafo de sputnik dice rusia ha
advertido repetidamente que ucrania está
planeando operaciones de bandera falsa
contra la central nuclear en un intento
por crear una zona de exclusión de hasta
30 kilómetros alrededor de la
instalación y desencadenar el despliegue
de fuerzas internacionales en el área
nos vamos a eeuu para ver qué dice
tienen básicamente cnn ese límite decir
que no puede verificar la autoridad de
los bombarderos de los bombardeos a los
alrededores de la central no estos
bombardeos de los que kiev y moscú se
acusan mutuamente vamos a francia con
limón si hemos querido señalar este
artículo que destaca hoy este periódico
francés que cita a rafael grossi
recordemos director general del
organismo internacional de energía
atómica quien esta semana declaró a
france 24 que estaba muy cerca ya el
acuerdo para que este organismo pudiera
visitar estas la nuclear más grande de
europa y la frase que destaca al humor
de la entrevista que le realiza a gross
y es no podemos añadir al drama de esta
guerra un accidente nuclear esperemos
sin duda que todos los actores
implicados en esta guerra lo vean así es
que es bien delicada rosa esta situación
en torno a esta central nuclear de
shapur y allá la masa grande de europa
pues es una información en desarrollo se
va actualizando literalmente cada 20
minutos cada minuto hay una información
nueva en torno a esta planta nuclear
vamos a cambiar ahora de tema rosa
precisamente uno de los temas que vamos
a tratar hoy en nuestro programa y ese
que ocurre en reino unido- vamos a
empezar a calentar entonces esta
conversación en este país europeo de
cara a digamos a a la elección final no
de quién será finalmente el nuevo primer
ministro el sucesor de boris johnson que
recordemos renunció todo esto empezó por
el escándalo de parís gate las fiestas
que hizo durante el confinamiento de la
pandemia de coín 19 que terminó entonces
en la renuncia tenemos dos candidatos
y también adicional ex ministro de
economía de boris johnson que está
pasando entonces en reino unido a vos
con the times que publicó un artículo
bien interesante esta semana
efectivamente y es que en un nuevo giro
de los acontecimientos de lo que es este
digamos esta trama de la política
británica de los últimos meses ahora the
times publicó que según una encuesta de
yougov el
49% de los votantes conservadores es
decir prácticamente a la mitad
preferiría que boris johnson
permaneciera en el cargo de primer
ministro en al lugar de que le ocupen
andrizzi zona como decías ex ministro de
finanzas o listas secretaria de
exteriores y es que digamos el 49% de
los votantes conservadores que
preferirían que boris johnson continuará
liderando el país supera el apoyo
combinado de los votantes conservadores
a ninguno de los 12 candidatos no claro
y según distintos artículos de prensa
este no es el único reproche que hacen
los británicos vamos con el diario punto
es exactamente qué
entre distintas consecuencias del break
sheet que la proporción de británicos
que piensan que la salida del reino
unido de la unión europea ha empeorado
sus vidas era del 30 por ciento en junio
de 2021 y ha pasado ahora al
45% mientras que el 52% de los
británicos considera directamente que
fue un error marcharse del bloque
comunitario de la unión europea frente
al 36% que piensan que fue un acierto
bueno rosa eso es lo que está pasando
entonces el reino unido de cara a quién
va a ser entonces el sucesor del primer
ministro británico boris johnson sin
embargo las encuestas hasta el momento
rosa necesitan bien ha tenido la
oportunidad de reír las le dan la
ventaja a litros a frente a dicha zona
no efectivamente rosa y llegamos al
final de esta semana en nuestra sección
de revista de prensa con un ranking que
publicó la revista forbes de los 50
países más bellos del mundo estamos en
uno de ellos efectivamente colombia
precisamente ocupa el tercer lugar no y
aquí la revista forbes colombia así lo
destacan 10 que colombia sólo estaría
superado según este ranking que publica
la revista forks basados en datos de
money puntocom you que si solamente
estaría superada colombia por indonesia
que sería el país considerado más bello
del mundo seguido de nueva zelanda en el
segundo lugar como bien decíamos
colombia en el tercero tanzania en el
cuarto y méxico en el quinto y también
una buena noticia para ti y raúl
venezuela extra en este ranking de los
50 países más bonitos del mundo ocupando
el lugar 39 claro imagino que todo esto
por todas estas riquezas naturales que
tienen todos estos países entre otras
cosas a colombia por supuesto con su
naturaleza su diversidad no pacífico
caribe pues está frío mejor dicho hay de
todo en este país y también las playas
venezuela que pues no ha tenido la
oportunidad de ver rosa pero pues que la
invitación está totalmente abierto
cuando quiera ya pasamos por los roques
o o puedes también ser el morrocoy
gracias raúl efectivamente es un ranking
basado en las maravillas naturales no
más que en cuestiones arquitectónicas
rosa muchísimas gracias entonces por
esta revista de prensa del día de hoy ya
feliz fin de semana nos vemos el lunes
con más información aquí en directo
américa de france 24 pasamos a ayudar a
nuestro primer invitado el día